all right welcome back everybody welcome
to mondays with monica at 6 41 new year
new you i know
we're all tired of wearing spanx i know
i am but
it is time to get your kitchen and gear
we got some kitchen cuisine for you
today
and joining me live via zoom is
celebrity chef gernard
wells you may know him as the host of
new soul kitchen and
new soul kitchen remix on clio tv he's
been on
people.com esses.com the food network
you know he's fancy like that that's why
we needed him on the show today
chef gennard how you doing
i am doing good good morning you know it
is truly a pleasure to be able to join
you guys out in the las vegas and the
surrounding
area of course i got family there the
whales and davis family i always love
showing up for them but it's all about
that great food like you say a new year
new you and that's what i'm trying to
bring it to you in a whole new element
i love that okay so chef let me make
sure i'm clear on this you take cause
you know soul food we love our sugar and
butter and cream and eggs and
you know southern chefs they don't like
all that fake stuff and all that diet
stuff
but you know how to take it twist it and
make it healthy
yeah and and that's what the whole gist
of what new soul kitchen remix is about
is showing you how to create dishes and
a fraction of the time with less of the
stuff that you don't want
we know everybody just want to modify
the diet so it's very simple what we're
going to do is a new orleans style
barbecue shrimp
simple all you do is you start off with
your butter we got some shrimp
we have some minced garlic
bay leaves yes yes yes yes the keys
of course this shrimp then we have some
worcestershire sauce worcestershire now
granted i always like to tell people if
they don't want to do the
shower sauce because you know it's made
with anchovies you could do the bragg's
amino acid and still get that same
experience
here we have some smoked paprika and
cayenne pepper just a little spice
because you know it's all about the
spice everything got a little spice it
ain't right
yeah and then we're going to use some
all-natural lemon pepper seasoning that
i create myself a
whole cuisine dot store take you some
fresh lemons
lay it in here lay it in here boom
squeeze add a little lemon juice and
these flavors really come together
so well look at how simple this is boom
crack
black pepper and what you want to do is
preheat your oven to 400 degrees
we pop this in the oven boom 20 minutes
and this is what it looked like right
here look at me man
you can't tell me yeah exactly see
and then what you do is you got your
little green onions because it's also
about presentation you know when you're
cooking dishes
we don't just eat with our noses but we
eat with our eyes too
and people always fall in love with the
way it looks
before it ever hits their mouth yeah so
top it off with some green onions there
and you got some good eating now you can
do this two ways me
love a little french bread if you want
to do a little bread every night in and
you just take those shrimp
right on there yeah right over the top
of it
right over the top all right here i'm
about running out of time here i know
you wanted to pair it with a drink for
them
yes i love it okay you got a drink real
quick things if you're doing this you
can do this for it
for britain for dinner breakfast lunch
uh
eating on the fraction i always say it's
good to go we need to stay hydrated
so you want to get you some nice good
fruited water here
and the key is included water is
warm water and with that warm water it's
gonna really pull out the flavors
so you got you some fresh mint we got
cucumbers we got strawberries we got
blueberries we got raspberries lemons
whatever
it is you have you want to dump all that
in and pour the warm
water over the top of it now
this trailer is just at those flavors
it's also like steeping and steeping it
just get you nice glass ice chill check
out this
love it all right chef i am out of town
out of town i am out of town
because you just made me hungry so i'm
getting myself confused here
but thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it tell everybody where they
can catch it because you're all over the
place these days
yes exactly every saturday 9 30
eastern new soul kitchen remix on cleo
tv i know you guys on this specific time
so you can catch us at 6 30 specific
standard time
or 9 30 specific your time as well all
right
chef junior wells thank you so much
folks check him out there oh yeah
he's going to come to vegas we had a
conversation i told him to bring it on
because we want him here in las vegas
and hey
that recipe i know you're thinking
monica give me the recipe just head on
over to our website eightnewsnow.com
it will be posted there for you and
don't forget hey tune in
to uh the mojo facebook live if you
missed the interview
you can catch it again on my show
tonight at 7 pm once again that's
moj show facebook live all right
that'll do it sherry